We are following the
latest developments from Ukraine,
where the military says
Russian forces are keeping up
a high rate of rocket attacks.
On the front lines in the east.
Ukraine says nearly
two dozen attacks were carried out
in just a 24 hour
period, primarily
focused in several cities
in Donetsk, including back Mount
and then the Turkish region as well.
Ukraine's military
also says Russia has set records.
They say hitting Ukraine's
east with artillery fire,
including in the Luhansk region.
Now, over the weekend,
Ukraine reported a massive barrage
of Russian attacks
right across the country.
Russia says it targeted key
energy facilities.
Despite that, the Ukrainian capital
and several regions
were able to avoid power cuts on Sunday.
President Vladimir Zelinski credits
those working to restore power.
Mr.
Putin, there is
the very
fact that after
constant terrorist attacks
with rockets and showerhead drones,
after a massive missile strike this week,
we can have such peaceful energy
days proves the professionalism
of our energy workers
and the extraordinary dedication
of everyone
who works to preserve our energy system.
My animals,
we have to realize
this is not yet a decisive victory
on the energy front.
Unfortunately,
there may be new terrorist
attacks from Russia.
CNN's David McKenzie
is following the latest developments
for us from Kiev.
In the last several days here in Ukraine,
the heaviest fighting has happened
on the eastern front of this conflict.
Ukrainian and Russian sources
even saying that
the Russian mechanized brigade
trying to push through the town.
Volodya saw significant losses.
And you see this
dramatic video of them being pushed back.
Sustained casualties
from drone and artillery strikes.
Now, the Defense Intelligence
of the United Kingdom
saying this is the worst period
of casualties for the Russians
since the very start of this war.
That's hard to stack up,
but certainly it's been
a very intense period of fighting there.
The Russian forces have had the forces
and in fact,
private military contractors
have had
somewhat more success
to the north of that town
in the Barmouth area.
But you're not seeing significant gains
of territory
in this period of attritional warfare.
Here in this conflict in Kiev
and the surrounds of the capital.
They are saying they have managed
to keep the lights on throughout the day,
which is a significant achievement,
says the energy minister,
because of those recent attacks
by missiles and drones by the Russians,
that many of them,
which the Ukrainians manage
to shoot down.
He also saying the repair work
is enabling them to keep the lights on.
That's significant
because Russia was looking
to break the spirit
of Ukrainian civilians
by targeting infrastructure,
something they haven't
been able to achieve.
David McKenzie, CNN, Kiev.
CNN Scott
McLean, is following developments
and joins us in London
now with the latest.
Scott, the head of the
a mercenary group goes
and has been talking about how essential
it is for the Russians
to capture back market
if they want to have,
I think you said, an easier time
basically capturing the rest of the east.
What are we hearing about the progress
there making?
It's pretty remarkable
considering the fact is a town
that surely very few people outside of
Ukraine would have even heard of
before the war.
Now it has
this really outsized importance
and it's that way for a few reasons.
A, it's been really a brick wall
for the Russians
for months and months
who've been trying to capture it.
And part of the reason
that they've had such
difficulty is because it is extremely
well fortified, both
naturally and militarily.
And so the Russians have
exhausted a
huge number of people,
a huge number of equipment,
and actually trying to take it
with really no luck.
And so as of late, their strategy
instead has been to go around it
to try to surround it.
And there are some indications
that they're having making progress.
Ukrainian military said
that there have been fierce battles
in towns
to the north of back
mud and also
to the west of Back Mount as well.
Which is concerning.
The Ukrainians also acknowledge
that, look,
their access in and out has been sporadic
as of late has been difficult
because many of the main routes
have been cut off.
And now just this morning,
we're learning
that the Bognor private
military contractor
claims to have captured
this town called Crossing of Horror,
which is just north of Park Moot.
In fact,
they posted a picture with their fighters
standing at the
southwest corner of the town.
And so
all of this paints a picture
that's not good for the Ukrainians,
despite the fact that Ukraine says
that, look, it's not
the Russians
that are wearing down
the Ukrainian troops
in the Ukrainian resolve.
They say that it's actually
the opposite,
that the
Ukrainians are rushing down
the Russians ability
to launch a major attack.
But this is pretty
optimistic view of a situation
that clearly is very difficult
for the Ukrainians.
And, of course,
we've seen this movie before
with several towns in that area where,
you know,
the Russians don't make any huge
one fell swoop
kind of breakthroughs,
but it's just sort of this slow
grinding move forward.
And that seems to be
what we're seeing now there today.
Scott McClain, thank you.